all right so we got sokka's master boy
that's an interesting tile I just saw
that I went like whoa what's gonna
happen in this episode and it's a good
one um the White Lotus the Okamoto so
that's little tile at the end what the
hell's that mean it that's exciting I
always want to learn more about the
Lotus people so yeah essentially they
decide that Sokka can't bend anything or
at least he decides that he can't bend
anything so he can't be of any great
worth or at least not as much as he
wants to be so they recommend that he
finds a masters someone to train him and
he goes to this guy in the Fire Nation
lies about who he is obviously and as if
he can be trained and the guy says he
never takes he almost never takes any
students they have to be someone special
and he's told to build himself up and
Sokka actually says I don't think I can
build myself up I'll be very honest I
don't think I'm very good I just always
want to try and of course the master
really likes then decides to train him
he trains him trains him great psycho
does a wonderful job at the very end he
admits who he is and the teacher has
this great big fight with him and of
course it's all part of the plan I mean
it's well we all kind of know the story
a bit but it's it's good and it works
effectively the only thing I really
question is the timeframe of it
especially like I have a big
conversation as you saw the last be log
about time and how much they really have
and I guess it's always kind of been a
strange kind of element and all this is
whether or not
how much does time really play in all
this because at times at times time
plays a big part in that it we gotta
keep going keep going through the meteor
coming there's also eclipse we have to
really do something about this but then
it's served like well we can take some
you know moments here to become a master
at something or to this or do that or
help these people out so it's kind of a
give and take but and apparently in this
all this is supposed to happen in one
day hey hey and I don't know about that
you could just
sort of say that's sort of the you know
family-friendly element of India nose or
the kid show element of it that you can
get away with a little bit more I don't
think anyone in reality would think oh
yeah you can learn all this in one day
that is very unlikely but you can't give
or take it's kind of the Disney aspect
don't really they fell in love in three
days okay the other cool thing about is
that we get more of uncle Iroh here and
I like how I the saddest image I saw at
first was when the guard came in and
he's there he's like drooling it just
got this mad look on his face I was just
like oh no that that can't be they they
kind of broken him like that and then he
starts doing the situps
and the push-ups and every single time
the guard comes in he acts like he's a
pig on the ground he's been broken as
pathetic as he leaves you like fritz
open the robe and a pillow falls off and
he's like filth it's both the
most awesome and hilarious moment makes
me laugh thinking about it but it's cool
it's and again I like reinforcing that
you know sir fooling your enemy and not
having so much pride that you have to
stand up to him and you know be strong
all the time it's in that illusion and
that you know being sort of deceitful
and mischievous and stuff but he's
always kind of been a big part of again
he's using it very much to his advantage
even in a place just like that cell so I
thought that was a really cool oh the
other thing I take a little bit of issue
with is that they're saying no you know
what it's akkad good at oh I don't know
it's like when he leaves they're like oh
there's no one to keep us on schedule or
tell jokes first of all I think I think
someone can keep a lot scheduled I mean
I I think you know at the very least
Katara could probably do that
and the joke thing I mean it's granted
people need levity they need humor and
again I know this very well
I mean it's like he's gone for a day and
it just like oh we just don't know what
to do we don't know how to do this or
whether it's a day or a couple days
whatever it is they make it look like a
day but even it's just a few days it's
like okay they're they're pushing it a
little bit but you kind of accept it but
what I would I always thought was kind
of weird was that you know even he was
kinda tizen I'm the idea guy I'm the guy
that thinks outside of the box and he
seemed very comfortable with it it seems
strange that he would come around to
feeling not very helpful when he seemed
to already find his groove before but I
like the idea of him finding a master
and I like the idea that the steel for
his sword is gotten from the meteorite I
thought that was a very cool idea
I'm sorry wondering that's gonna play a
part in any other way because it why
specifically I know it's just
interesting you have that sort of hit
the earth and they make a sword out of
it well how is that gonna come back that
seems like something that would come
back I'm curious if it does it comes
like everything else in this show seems
to so yeah sure I think what else in
this one yeah it's a basic training
episode but it's it's done well you know
the guy's voice the teacher I felt let
me look up who that is I'm actually
gonna look up the name right now but
that's the beginning the next episode I
want to see if that's anybody because Oh
Robert Patrick okay um I didn't like him
very much
it wasn't awful or anything like that I
just thought it was kind of this very it
sounded like someone who was doing a
voice and for a cast that is so good at
not sounding like that it was a touch
distracting um that's not to say he was
bad I mean he'd la Zed I serve oversold
that a little bit I mean he's not bad
but yeah I think of someone I think of
Mako and I think of Dante Basco and and
the people who do the voices of the kids
definitely just sound very very natural
especially for a family show like this
aunt animated that's very difficult to
do and they got they just got that so
well and I thought his just something
about the way he talks you know it was
very much Kemosabe I must show you were
the way of the wind I don't know it it
didn't quite sound right um but it
wasn't bad I still like the character I
mean it wasn't like oh he ruined what
was a great character no it still came
across what he was about and you know
how he'll kind of quirky he could be and
eccentric but also how a very calm very
focused and you know an overall good
teacher and obviously all the twists at
the end you kinda know her coming that
he wouldn't know he'd be up against the
avatar when he's fighting Sakai he's
fighting to really test him and so forth
so yeah I mean it it works I mean I'm
not saying like it destroyed anything
I'm saying just if anything just
compared to the rest of the actors his
didn't quite have the his thing quite
wasn't quite on the same level as
everyone else but again this guy is best
known for playing you know an
emotionless robot so there you go
it wasn't quite an emotional spot but I
just Justin grabbed me as much as say a
lot of the other actors did uh with that
said yeah can't think of too much else
to talk about in this one I'm glad Sakai
knows how to use the sword and I don't
know where Suki is okay am I saying it
right now it's a su ki saw so in it she
like tried to spell it out like su and
the - and then like k eh or something
like that so hopefully I'm saying it
right I think things to ki that's what
she says in Suki Suki I don't cares um
but that's like the one thing is on my
mind right now ever since I thought I'm
like wait yeah where is she where does
she go where the other warriors go I'm
so confused by this um you know maybe
she got away cuz the more I think of no
but she was fighting as a okay wow I'm
really overthinking this bottom line
good episode you know I'm not a great
one but it's nice to see Sokka certainly
get more to
then I cactus I wonder where that I
don't know where that Lotus thing is
heading towards I wonder what they're
gonna do with that so um yeah that's
about it and I'll see you next episode